as you can see we are sitting at a brand
new table and it's also time to announce
our brand new co-host seat at the top
table so raise your glass and welcome
our new talk co-hosts
it's official you are the new member of
the swamp what does it mean to be a host
I'm so excited I mean to be able to be a
part of this panel with these wonderful
incredible dynamic smart funny real
women I'm jazz I'm excited what was it
like and when did you know and what was
the call like what was the call like I
cried yeah cuz you know I've been guest
hosting for like I think over a year now
oh it's gonna make me cry I got so it
felt like I ran a marathon like I since
the first time I was on the set I just
felt like I I loved these women and I
had so much to grow by being with them
and like I just cried I'll actually lay
down in my hallway and I was like oh my
god I actually get to do this for a
living this gets to be my job it gets to
come here and be with these incredible
women and learn and share with them I'm
lucky very fortunate
[Applause]
I think she's the right person because
she feels like that how great is that I
I think you know I mentioned it on the
show but I really feel like she's our
friend and that is what the show is
about it's about being girlfriends
sharing and being honest she's always
got something to say she's always
bringing it to the table and we just
feel connected to her and that's
everything and also to she said wow up
parties this one parties is her you to
balance this with Dancing with the Stars
because that's still no season in the
spring but still in the fall
well what's great is I have this spring
to get used to this schedule coming into
work every day I've never had a job
where I've come in every day in my
entire life and I think Dancing with the
Stars was greatest because it's live and
we just judged I show up after the talk
and it works out perfectly I couldn't
have asked for a more ideal situation
and what did it mean also to get Julie's
endorsement before she left she was very
welcoming and loving toward you Carrie
Anne I don't know but in my opinion you
look awful good sitting in that chair my
Asian sister I'm just saying
Julie has been exceptionally loving and
I have so much respect for her she sent
me flowers she's one of the first people
to send me flowers and I just have so
much love in my heart for her she's a
strong woman and I know she's going
through a lot and I just send her all my
love and I'm so grateful for her
[Music]